welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Eckert from a professor of a ciri
ology at Yale his main research
interests are Assyrian and Babylonian
history and Mesopotamian scholarly texts
of the first millennium BCE his courses
at Yale include topics in Mesopotamian
history religion and literature and the
Bible in its ancient near-eastern
setting professor Fromm has authored
several books including Babylonian and
Assyrian texts commentaries origins of
interpretation he is currently in the
process of of creating an online portal
that provides key information and full
editions of these commentaries today we
talk with professor from about the
psycho history of an Assyrian King
welcome professor from thank you very
much and thank you for the invitation of
course so how did you become interested
in a siri ology well perhaps I should
first start explaining a little bit
about a story ology actually is mix it
up is even worse with astrology or so
but in fact our ology is scholarly
disciplined and explores the ancient
Near East that is with the the languages
cultures and history of ancient Iraq
ancient Syria and to a certain extent
also ancient Iran and ancient Turkey it
is particularly focused on texts of
which there are many there some several
hundreds of thousands of ancient
documents written in cuneiform is it's
not paper is it is it some other
substance the ancient Mesopotamians
actually brought on clay and that is
very fortunate for us because unlike a
library like with with books when it
when it burns down everything is lost
clay when it is being fired actually
that's even harder and is almost
indestructible and that is the reason
why we have so many documents from the
ancient Near East so that is very
curious to me because I would imagine
there
are they very heavy they can be often
enough the tablets are broken when they
have found and so we have to reassemble
them because adjoining but of course
they are heavier then let's say a book
or scroll and so for instance
letter-writing meant that the scribes
would write in very very small script on
the clay in order to make sure that the
transport of these documents would be
fairly easy and yeah I understand Yale
has a very fine collection it does in
fact a year Babylonian collection is the
largest collection of Canadian texts in
the United States it has some
thirty-five thousand documents which is
a substantial number and these are all
clay tablets these are essentially all
clay tablets we also have a number of
seeds some of which inscribed but
primarily these are tablets representing
all sorts of texts from literature and
religious texts to everyday documents
such as letters legal deeds and so on so
there's hardly anything that is not
represented in the Babylonian collection
here so what led you to study yeah I
mean I was of course not aware of the
richness of this field when I was a
child and it was not my intention when I
was let's say ten in ten years o to
becoming a psychologist actually wanted
to become sportscaster at that time but
on the radio not on television this is
really my natural environment but then
when in high school I had the
opportunity to study Hebrew Biblical
Hebrew out of curiosity I didn't want to
become a minister anything but I
realized when reading the Hebrew Bible
that all these stories about the ancient
Babylonians and Assyrians about their
kings about the downfall of Assyrian
alanya and so on and then intrigued me
and by studying Hebrew we also studied a
Semitic language and the main language
of ancient Mesopotamia Akkadian is
likewise Semitic so it is related to
Hebrew so I became a little bit
interested in that an Akkadian is a
language very well documented in the
records
we have some well probably more than
half a million of texts in Akkadian
alone so we have probably more texts and
Akkadian from the ancient world and in
Latin only a Greek has a larger number
of texts and that was another thing I
realized that there's still a lot to be
done most of these texts actually are
not yet published and I found it
challenging to do that and kind of
exciting
I also chatted a little bit in the
region I went to Turkey eastern Turkey
and to Syria and saw some of the sights
and so that was eventually what
motivated me to to get into this this
fear which seems small and obscure but
the texts document a period reaching
from the mid 4th millennium down to the
time of Christ
so it's essentially the first half of
history so I would claim it's not quite
as marginal as Annette seen it and do
these texts span a wide range of topics
for instance are there any kind of
besides the deeds and legal forms are
there any other kinds of texts that they
would have written they definitely are
and I mentioned literary texts of the
earliest literature actually is from
ancient Mesopotamia these are epics and
myths but we also have humorous
decomposition humor we have many
scholarly texts at the beginning of
mathematics and ancient philology are
not with the ancient Greeks even though
I do not want to deny that the geeks
created something that was in many ways
you the earliest philology the earliest
mathematics this is all angel
Mesopotamia so there's a theorem of
pythagoras for instance is not something
the biggs came up with it is attested in
the 18th century BC in Mesopotamia
already very interesting all right so
let's talk about your paper Family
Matters the psycho historical
reflections on Sinatra
am I saying that correctly and his times
so tell us about the paper and who that
Assyrian King was sure
Sennacherib is actually the Hebrew Bible
version of that very name in Assyrian
his name was seen ok Arriba so
Sennacherib was in a certain king who
ruled from 705 to 681 BC
he would doing an important period this
was the time when perhaps for the first
time in human history there was such a
thing as an empire it can be debated
what really constitutes an empire and
there is no consensus whether the
Assyrians really were the first ones to
have won but what they did have was a
state of massive size ranging
essentially from the armenian highlands
in the north down to the persian guys in
the south and from the Zagros Mountains
in Iran to the Levant and even down to
Egypt it was also a multi-ethnic and
multilingual Empire with many different
people being represented it was well
organized in in provinces and there was
a kind of osmotic flow of taxes and and
tribute from the periphery to the center
was ruled in a very centralized way with
one king in charge who of course relied
on a well-equipped military and a
well-educated administration and and all
that sort of is what what I would say it
was it was the blueprint for all the
later empires in the engineer you
starting with the Babylonians and the
Persians but even down to the to the
about to the Islamic states of the a
passage and the Ottomans this I think is
what gives the Assyrian Empire of an
important place in world history it's
also I mean should add that perhaps the
place in which the Israelites and the
Judeans developed their their
monotheistic ideas and that certainly
happened to some extent in response to
the experience of a mana critique king
namely the Assyrian King so that had an
impact as well so Sennacherib ruled this
large Empire towards the end of the 8th
and the beginning of the seventh century
BC some of the sort of key achievements
militarily and politically were his
campaign against the Rev and famous
among other things through a report in
the Bible about this campaign and his
attack on Jerusalem he managed in the
end to become the master of this way
and at the same time his conflict with
Babylonia in 689 he actually destroyed
the city of Babylon an event that had
some long-term consequences and was of
of great significance but he also sort
of was active in more constructive ways
he is the king who turned the city of
Nineveh also famous from the Bible and
also known from Greek sources into the
greatest metropolis of his age with a 12
kilometer long walls around they get
massive palaces and temples inside he
was very interested in architecture he
was very interested in architecture he a
Tory why Crown Prince been engaged in
the building activities of his father
Tsar on the second and he also that's
another interesting aspect about him
built of canals and aqueducts to make
sure that the agricultural production
around anyway and in this area in
general what would grow so this was
another other sort of impressive
achievement of his reign and he
describes it at great length in his
texts which does indeed as you say
indicate that this was I wouldn't call
it a hobby but something that he really
was very interested in so let's talk a
little bit about the psycho historical
aspects of him tell us a little bit
about the insights that you've come up
with in terms of the research that
you've done and why it really is kind of
a departure to look at the like a
psychoanalysis of him virtues versus the
other impacts that he's had sure perhaps
I should first say that psycho history
actually has a very bad name among
contemporary serious contemporary
historians I think I don't know who's
LaVon said that great minds discuss
ideas average Minds discuss events and
small minds discuss people and that is
essentially that essentially epitomizes
what many many historians today believe
only that they would not claim that it
is so much ideas they determine history
but other systems or structures economic
institutions
ideologies and so on all these abstract
forces now I am of course absolutely
fine with the idea that all these things
are important I would not deny that but
that said I also do believe that
personal individual whims that of
individual historical actors that their
experiences in their family lives and
what what kind of trauma Tirso came out
of that likewise did have an effect on
the unfolding of history of course
especially since he controlled virtually
everything that was going on I mean that
is of course something that applies
specifically to a situation where you
have one Lula who was really very much
in charge of things so in this case the
the psychological infrastructure of that
very gula I think really doesn't matter
the experiences of his youth or later
life with his parents his siblings his
his wives or husbands all that I think
really does matter and death shape to
some extent the politics of that very
individual so this is anyway not
[ __ ] now of course I'm well aware of
the of the methodological problems of
retroactive psychoanalysis it's really
hard to know exactly what was going on
naive I mean we're dealing here with
individuals who lived more than 2,500
years ago and I Moulton most definitely
not in Orthodox Freudian or so so I'm
applying psychology in a very news way
but what I do try to establish in this
paper is whether I can show that certain
sort of events from Senecas family life
did not have have an impact on the way
he would Surya and his politics in
general and one meta that stands out
here I would say is his relationship
with his father whose name I mentioned
Sauron the second a very powerful King
in his own right a great military man
with whom Sannikov originally seems to
have had a pretty good relationship
he was his crown prince from early on
Sennacherib represented his father while
his four
spent three years Babylon he received
well tribute bring us from all of the
Empire he was engaged in in collecting
military intelligence we have letters
from this time so we get a lot of
information about his political
formation from these letters
we also learned a little bit about his
private life from them all this seems
pretty ok but then there are a few
things where we can see that there's a
growing rift between Ackerman his father
one is that Sargon jakub's father
marries another woman makes her his new
queen
snacker was probably afraid that perhaps
if that women woman had a head and had a
child that child might become Campins in
his dad she probably did yeah it looks
like it and Seneca was also not happy
with mmm sarang's babylonian politics
there was a very special relationship
between Babylonia and Assyria it was a
little bit like between the Greeks and
the Romans the Assyrians in a way
represent the Romans here so they wanted
to rule a bolonia but they acknowledged
that Babylonia was the source of of
culture and civilization and religion
and that is the case the Assyrians got
much of their literature their religion
and so on from Babylonia and Sauron it
was a very probable Oh nian he wanted to
rule Babylonia but he was also willing
to give Pablo Nia a lot of privileges
tax exemptions etc and he spent his
three years there and it seems was not
something that the syrup proved off but
what really caused an almost traumatic
shift in his relationship to his father
was the death of his father which
occurred in 705 BCE when Sargon went on
a campaign ton a tall young witch he was
killed by local insurgents and what was
even worse was that his body could not
be recovered he couldn't be buried and
it wasn't very bad answer yeah there
must have been great fear that
henceforth his his his ghost would haunt
the living we have for instance evidence
that one of the most important serene
scholars immediately after the news of
sarang's death reached
syria
copied the Tres tablet of the Gilgamesh
epic the most famous literary text from
ancient Mesopotamia at the end of which
we have a discussion between Anka do and
Gilgamesh the two protagonists about
what happens to someone who dies in
enemy country and kind of be buried and
it's very bad so this man this scholar
was clearly concerned about that there's
also a text in which Sannikov
investigates the nature of the sin of
Sargon that led to his death in the
engineers there was this believed that
when something terrible happens to you
you must have caused it in some way and
thereby have attracted the rage of the
gods in a way yes you could say so so
nothing happens without the reason and
it is very clear that from that moment
onwards the moment of sarang's death
when Sennacherib became king he
distanced himself very much from his
father
Sargon had built a massive new capital
himself and had inaugurated in just one
year before his death but soon a crypt
just simply leaves this massive new city
and moves to Nineveh he does not want to
dwell there anymore he builds a temple
for the netherworld god that certainly
is also in response to the death of his
father but never mentioned severe
reasoning lead sarang's death he hides
some of the reliefs that Sargon created
the religious capital of Assyria osawa
and most important he never mentions his
father in his inscriptions
he imitates these inscriptions
occasionally but so his relationship was
somewhat ambivalent but he clearly does
not follow sovereigns politics this is
most obvious with respect to Babylonia
there we can see that unlike Sauron who
privileged Babylonia Sennacherib doesn't
want to do that he doesn't even want to
be king of Babylonia so instead what he
does he puts a local Babylonian up as
the Babylonian king as a puppet ruler
later on when that doesn't work out he
makes one of his sons the king of
Babylon and why did not why didn't he
want to be the king of Babylon yet
because his father had favoured them I
think so I think it would have meant
that he would have provided the message
that yes the Assyrians favored the
Babylonians more than anyone else
that was something apparently
Sennacherib didn't want to do so he
wanted a more indirect way of
controlling Babylonia and he was
apparently also yeah I mean his
relationship to Babylonian culture was
was ambivalent but but he was probably
to some extent more of a necessary
nationalist and his father was even
though of course that are national ism
is is kind of an acoustic in the end the
Babylonians killed the neck of Sun in
694 who was their King and that must
have enraged as an Arab even more so
here we have another case where well
what is essentially personally then
leads to two future political action in
this case the complete destruction of
Babylon which is an event that happened
in 689 and that years and occurred and
it was really quite quite unprecedented
it was as though as if the Romans had
destroyed Athens decided to completely
destroy the city and and he did that and
this again had long-term consequences
because the Babylonians never forgot
what Sennacherib had done they
remembered in it in their texture record
centuries after they were still aware of
this event and it stands to reason that
when the Babylonians together with the
needs in 614 and 612 destroyed the
Assyrian cities of Usher and any day
that they did this in in revenge for the
previous destruction of their own city
bison accurate so of course Cenac had
all sorts of reasons to act the way he
did against Babylonia but I do think
that these personal ones did play a role
and I would argue that you can see here
sort of a chain of events that may
originally have been rooted in in
personal feelings becoming then
eventually sort of a spectacle on them
and the world historical stage okay very
interesting and in terms of the
methodology you you basically glean this
from the research that you've done the
reading of these texts yes essentially I
do I have actually studied certain royal
inscriptions for a long time and those
of Sennacherib is
ashle and the sauce is average there are
some 600 inscribed objects with texts
written in the name of Sennacherib alone
presenting some 200 different texts I
already mentioned they roll on clay and
often enough these these inscriptions
which can be very long some have some
1000s of lines but they are often broken
so one of the challenges is to just
simply piece them together what you do
is you go to the museums where these
inscriptions are housed most important
with respect to the Assyrians is the
British Museum but there's lots of
friends in Chicago and then you try to
identify duplicates you try to join text
when you're very fortunately you
actually managed to make transatlantic
joints I once managed to join a couple
of fragments kept in the Chicago
Oriental Institute with fragments kept
in London that somehow got there
independently so these of course are
that was a very exciting piece of these
are exciting moments when you are a
scholar that's true but in the end the
goal of course is to to get a good idea
of what Sennacherib actually wrote down
now these are not strictly speaking
autobiographies even though they're
written in the name of the king and the
king is the only real protagonist but
ever written we know that as well
bye-bye ghostwriter so to speak
who who ever consulted the King we have
letters in which these ghost writers
asked the King to provide some
information on what he wanted to have
covered in these inscriptions so we can
assume that they do really to some
extent at least represent the division
of the king himself we also have other
tanks for instance letters or so which
of course I mentioned the ones from San
Arabs time is a conference which are
less sort of ideological ideologically
charged as you can imagine the royal
inscriptions
present a very king centered image word
history the letters deal with fear
problems there's no time for ideological
bomb past they really need to address
the actual problems and we also have a
couple of chronicles which I like was
fairly objective give us a good
chronological skeleton of the events
happen
and sometimes refer to events that were
not so great for let's say the Assyrians
and so altogether I do believe we have a
fairly substantial number of sources
also lucky that snack table actually
mentioned some of these family related
aspects of his life in his inscriptions
that is quite unusual he doesn't mention
especially several of his wives to such
an extent that a scholar actually has
asked some of rhetorically the question
was inaccurate a feminist certainly goes
to find I think no modern feminists
would actually subscribe to that idea
but it is true that we have a lot of
information on these women and they
played an important role as well
especially when it came to Sanok of
succession
Sennacherib had two main wives who
served as Queens Terra
he also had her and a lot herons and
various cities like all the serene kings
but these kings had usually won uh
occasionally more than one main' wives
who served in an official capacity as a
Syrian clean and it seems that the one
who whose sons were originally meant to
succeed Sennacherib at some point was
sidelined by a second wife
Nakia and it was the son of that second
wife who eventually became the next
assyrian king it is interesting in fact
is another case where I think one kind
of fly in a way the idea of
psychohistory
it's interesting to see that under
Sennacherib the Assyrian state god
ashore
suddenly has two wives as well two
divine spouses one of them is named
Melissa and the other one is cher who
and I can't prove it but it seems
tempting to me that in a way his neck
was projecting his own kind of family
life on to the divine sphere just as he
had these two main wives his god had to
have these two wives as well so what
happened to Sinatra eventually well all
his attempts of distance himself on his
father perhaps to be protected and not
to suffer the same fate this father has
had suffered actually failed because due
to the to the conflicts about his
succession
the elder sons one of whom have been
company and have been eventually
replaced by this son of the other woman
this elder son actually conspired
against Sennacherib Sennacherib had sent
this new Crown Prince to the West in
order that seems to protect him from
attacks of his elder brothers it was a
little bit like a Shakespearean drama in
fact but he didn't change his mind about
the succession and that prompted this
elder son of this the former Crown
Prince to murder him and so in 681 he
was killed by this by this man we have
reference to this murder in the
Babylonian Chronicle in a serene letter
and even in the Hebrew Bible do you know
how he was killed well it is it is not
entirely clear my own take in it using
several sources is that he was probably
killed with a sword while entering a
temple at Nineveh but they're not
poisoned no he was probably not poisoned
but we cannot be entirely sure and the
Bible claims he was killed with a sword
but that may be actually a top house so
we have no Assyrian Babylonian source
that would exactly say how he was killed
but one text
intriguingly says that he was killed
between Bull colossi who may have seen
in in in in in the Metropolitan Museum
this massive stone colossi that guarded
the entrances of Assyrian palaces and
temples and so the question here is was
it just standing between the colossi
when he was killed or were these kalasa
in some ways thrown over in which is
some scholars believe I think that's
unlikely if you realize how big yes
so it's a nice idea but I'm afraid it's
probably not correct okay so I would
imagine that some of the these texts
have made its way into the the portal
that you're working on and of course the
publication so let's talk about that a
little bit tell us about the project
yeah the project I'm engaged in right
now is not related in any way directly
to politics
sort of mother's intellectual history
and she was opinio is the place where
for the first time in human history you
have text commentaries so what's the end
of the second millennium Mesopotamian
scholars began to serialize and canonize
their scholarly traditions divinity
attacks medical texts literary texts and
others these texts from then on could no
longer be changed it was no longer
really possible to edit them just like
well the Bible can no longer be changed
that led to a need among the scholars to
comment on these texts in order to make
sure that they will remain accessible
was well I mean these texts remained in
in place for for roughly 1,000 years and
they became to some extent of course
difficult to understand so in the first
half of the first millennium BCE we we
see the production in Mesopotamia both
in Assyria and in the South in Babylonia
of hundreds of commentary texts in a way
sort of first Babylonian Talmud some of
which simply explain let's say the names
of plants and medical texts explaining
what these plants actually are
describing them also others more
sophisticated trying to establish
additional layers of meaning kind of an
esoteric interpretation of this
tradition these texts have never been
collected in any way and many actually
remain unpublished and the project I'm
engaged in right now together with a
postdoc and we can Anna's from Spain who
is here da right now is to gather them
to edit them to provide introduction to
them these texts are very difficult
among the most difficult texts available
for Mesopotamia and to make the
additions plus photos and introductions
available online we hope that we will
get an additional grant right now I'm
able to have some money to pay my
postdoc but it is a fairly massive
project given the fact that there are
almost 1000 of these commentaries so it
will take a couple of years to complete
this but I think if we manage to do that
and I hope you will and
we are about to launch the site very
soon towards the end of this year so
then there will be introduction so there
are a couple of additions will be out
there many filters will be available so
if we manage to continue that I think
that this will become an important
resource for anyone interested in
intellectual history so anyone will be
able to access it anyone should be able
to access it yes wonderful very good and
it let's fast forward to today and I'm
wondering how the current situation in
Syria and Iraq are affecting the work
that you that you've done or will do
yeah of course I mean for our theologist
and even more so for instant
archaeologists the situation in Iraq
essentially since the iran-iraq war in
1918 has been catastrophic but at least
until 2001 2002 it was still possible to
do some kind of excavations there since
then this has become very difficult and
do you think anything has been ruined or
destroyed yes and at the same time of
course what we have seen happening was
that illicit digging increased massively
so this has led to the situation in Iraq
where many many important texts have
appeared on the market that came that do
come from these illicit excavations
conducted by local people who sell the
stuff to to middlemen who then sell them
on to traders all over the world whether
it's in the in the Arab world or Japan
Europe or United States this has caused
kind of an ethical dilemma for scholars
working on texts obviously these
excavations these illicit excavations
destroy contacts and it's it's a shame
because we have the opportunity in Iraq
to find ancient libraries in the entire
team we can reconstruct what people
there actually studied what kind of text
I read by looking at the ensemble of
texts and that of course longer possible
when you deal with these stolen tablets
so some archaeologists especially have
argued one should not really look at
these texts at all because they do come
from these illicit excavations I have to
say though that given
that there are really tens of thousands
of these tanks flooding the markets that
I think it is impossible to ignore them
and some of these texts are truly
important for instance a recent
publication included the first law text
from anywhere in the world the laws of
horn a know in a very well preserved
version and it is just impossible not to
study their text so the situation in
Iraq was bad enough for many decades
that led most archaeologists of migrate
to Syria a very good work has been done
since nineteen nineteen eighty and up to
2011 but when the Civil War broke out in
Syria of course the situation they had
deteriorated as well and right now
no excavations are possible in Syria
either this has led archaeologists to
migrate to Kurdistan which is the only
regions of in the central in the core
area of Mesopotamia where you can't
still excavate and archaeologists also
excavating in in Turkey with Isis taking
over power in this region this situation
has probably become even worse because
now Isis also actively destroys finds
that are being made especially Wendy saw
visual things statues also which are
deemed pagan and therefore in the view
of these people should not be out there
so some months ago Isis posted a number
of photos of a distraction of statue
found in télécharger in eastern Syria
the Khabur River is the ancient city of
shadi Connie the statue apparently of an
Assyrian King with what seems to be a
very interesting inscription I've tried
to decipher it and you can read a number
of lines quite well and the text yields
with the Persians and a campaign against
the West and is provides information on
the local cuts in took in in in Saudi
County it is a very interesting and
important text but the photos of
course--i who were the statue has been
destroyed so this situation is of course
deeply frustrating but it is important I
think
right now to intensify actually our
endeavors to deal with the material to
make sure that we keep track of what is
coming out as I said I mean it will be
hundreds tens of thousands perhaps
hundreds of thousands of texts that will
eventually be show up somewhere on the
market in private collections or
wherever and and I do believe we have to
somehow publish these texts despite the
fact that the way they were found is is
very regrettable right well this has
been fascinating thank you so much for
being here today with us and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
was a pleasure to have an opportunity to
do so okay for more information about
professor from and his work please visit
our website at Yale edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale